Hãy quyết định mới nguyên hợp được sự dụng kết quả học tập đặt tích lưỡi, để tiếp tục hợp ở chính độ ca hơn.
Phó khóan thành một chính trình đào tạo khá có cùng chính độ, phù hợp với không chính độ của SaVie Nam.
Nguyên hợp lên thông sẽ học theo chính trình đào tạo hiện hàng của chính độ tương ứng.
Hối lượng học tập thực tế, đô xa đỉnh những chính cơ sở kết quả cơm nhận và truyền lỗi chính trình.
Đó xây dự lộ chính học tập phù hợp với tương cá nhân.
Đáng chú ý là người học lên thông được ám dụng thông như các điều kiện về học tập, kiểm tra đánh giá thông nhận tương nghiệp và cấp bằng những những sinh viên khác trong cụu chính trình đào tạo.
Điều này có phần bảo đam trên lộ đồng gia và tính công bằng dựa cơ đối tượng người học.
Vì tình sinh lên thông tiếp tục được thực hiện theo cuy chế tuyển sinh hiện hàng của tương chính độ đào tạo.
Đối với các hành đào tạo sống viên nhóm hành xe khỏc cấp dế phép hành nghỉ.
Pháp lợp, quốc phòng, an ninh và các hành đặc thủ khác.
Vì tình sinh và tổ chính đào tạo vấn vài tôn thuộc quy định chuyên hàng.
Một trong những nghiệm mới nổi bật của tương tương ở lòng ăn thiện cơ chi công nhận kết quah học tập và chuyển đổi tính chỉ.
Theo đào, kết quả nực xem xét công nhận không chỉ bao gồm gà phần 1 hạt 1 đuôn đá hoàn thành.
Đại các cơ sở giáo dụng trong nước.
Mà còn có thể là kết quah học tập tại các cơ sở giáo dụng nước ngoài, chính chỉ giáo dụng đại học, chính chỉ kiến năng nghe của xe
và các tết quah học tập khác được pháp rượt công nhận.
Mày công nhận được tục hiện trên cơ sở nổi sáng, chuẩn, đâu ra, nổi zoom trưng trình khối lượng hợp tập phòng pháp nánh giá,
và mức độ đặc nục của người học bây giờ cầu của các trưng trình đào tạo.